Mistake.
No,
this is one of the reasons that I did I
take the biblical elections I did last
year were so helpful for me.
And I think one of the things that's
quite interesting about those stories,
even having stories in particular,
those bloody people,
they just make mistakes all the time.
Absolutely.
So Abraham,
for example,
no,
he was chosen by God.
I politically like all the people there
and I mean he just pick one absolutely
catastrophic mistake after another.
And so that's life man making
in regretting huge mistakes.
Now that doesn't mean that you should
just go on and drop again the mistakes.
So you have to take responsibility for
the people that I watched in my life
lived probably that say they
learned from the mistakes,
but they didn't beat themselves
to death because of the,
you know,
when you think,
well,
so this says,
well this was a regretted it to validate.
It's like,
well we don't take adult term is
out in the public square and stone.
And so you probably shouldn't
do that to yourself.
You know,
if you regret it,
well then what you have to do is if you
have to repent and you have to atone.
Okay.
And so what's reprint unrepentant,
Nate?
It meets well,
it means you have to go over what you
did and you have to figure out now that
you know it was a mistake,
who after figuring out why
you were Sadam clueless,
it's a damn stupid and
exactly what we did wrong.
Like with each the decision point,
like you know when you first met the
person that you have the affair with,
you probably flirted with him
a little bit more than that.
Then you probably flirted with them to
a degree that you regarded as risky and
access,
but you did it anyways.
Snow.
You have to figure out,
well,
why in the world did I
think that was a good idea?
Then you have to know exactly.
So if you're,
if you're walking down a path and you'd
get lost and you wander off the path and
you get lost,
you have to figure out how it is
that you wandered off the path.
Because the purpose of of repaired take
let's say is so good when you're back on
the path.
First of all,
you can find your way back.
That would be the first purpose and the
second is so you don't wonder off again.
And if you wondered off once that your
pro for wandering off in that matter and
so then you'd have to figure out why
your program to wandering off for that
matter right down into the most painful
level of detail and then you have to
figure out how not to do it again and
then as soon as you figure out how not to
do it again,
then you should start beating yourself up.
You know,
because you've learned your lesson.
That's sort of the principle.
I tried out bloods in
principles of discipline for
children in chapter five what
is the best principles?
Is you still more forced than this
necessarily minimal necessary for us,
it's a great,
it's a great rule of thumb and you use
that on yourself when you make mistakes,
you know and make you so
you have to figure out thing
when you get wrong by your
own criteria.
When you said you did something wrong,
you said you regretted it.
Okay,
you did something wrong because
otherwise you would regret it.
Or Nesbitt,
you're just regretting the fact that
fucked up your life and you actually,
you know what that's,
that's feeling sorry for yourself.
That's not regretting.
It's,
you're going to have to sort those
things out because you don't get to feel
sorry for yourself.
You just get to regret it.
And if you've read regretted
me to did something wrong,
and then you have to
out what you did wrong.
Exactly right down to the detailed
levels and what was wrong with your
perception and your beliefs
that led you in that direction.
Everyone would have to do to put that
right and then you have to put it right
and then maybe you have to go around and
make it manage to over people that you
heard.
And then you have to be that.
And then perhaps you'll find
yourself back on the path.
And then you have to stay
on the path as best you can.
And if that's the case in some sense,
because if we all had to pay
the ultimate price for our sins,
every single one of us
would be [inaudible].
So we are just as part of why the
concept of original sin and so useful and
everyone feels it because
everyone's guilty.
Never one's ashamed of themselves.
So we have this inbuilt sense of something
going wrong and if we can name it
haunts us.
And that's why the idea of
original sin is so useful,
even though it has perhaps some
conceptual problems associated with it.
And perhaps it's not all good.
But in this particular situation,
you know you're a bad person
but soon as everyone else.
So it doesn't mark you out
as a particularly horrible.
That doesn't mean the
horribleness isn't real,
but it's not just you.
And then what you do about it
is you're trying to be better.
And that's what you do about what's
wrong with you to begin with.
Every,
every one of us,
we've all got things to learn,
man.
And plenty of them.
The world is what it could be in.
That's our fault.
And so we've got lots
to learn and so to you,
and you try and learn and you
treat yourself with affirm enough,
had something you learn and not a harsh
enough handsome that you've died while
you're learning.
That's
[inaudible] zero.
That's the end of the night.
[inaudible].